[Música]
en 2012 el nuevo año llegó con una nueva
moneda
desde ese primero de enero el euro se
convirtió en la moneda de circulación
oficial en la unión europea el adiós de
las pesetas las liras los marcos los
francos
en la antesala de esa conversión los
bancos europeos repartían paquetes con
la nueva moneda para que la gente
empezara a familiarizarse con ella cada
país fijó su periodo de transición al
euro fueron varios meses de margen para
cambiarse a la nueva moneda en algunas
ocasiones con sorpresas para más de uno
la torre eiffel por ejemplo adoptó de
inmediato el euro como único método de
pago algo que impactó a los turistas hoy
el euro está presente en 19 países de
los 27 estados miembros de la unión
todavía con algunos nostálgicos
el marco alemán era bueno el euro es un
desastre un desastre software catástrofe
era la expresión kebab por ejemplo se
transformó directamente a euros fue una
sorpresa pero el precio cayó con el paso
del tiempo
en estos 20 años el euro se ha
establecido como la segunda divisa más
importante del mundo sólo por detrás del
dólar estadounidense en este periodo la
moneda ya ha superado momentos difíciles
entre ellos la crisis económica del 2008
ahora el banco central europeo piensa en
una reinvención impulsada en parte por
la pandemia y el rechazo al dinero
físico se trata del euro digital un
proyecto de dinero electrónico para
complementar al efectivo